sie gehören zu den rund 200 millionen
monatlichen nutzern von snapshots kamen
bärfuss und nina jahren aus berlin
mit der app verschicken sie foto oder
video nachrichten so genanntes netz an
freunde typisches netz
die zahlreichen bildbearbeitungs tools
das besondere die empfänger können
dieses netz höchstens zehn sekunden lang
sehen danach löschen sie sich und selbst
benutze ist eigentlich in meinen
freunden zu zeigen wo ich gerade bin
oder mit wem ich gerade bin was ich
gerade mache anzahl von sekunden
sehr oft patterson zählt zu den
einflussreichsten cnet chattern europas
dem norweger folgen rund 50.000 fans
er erstellt so genannte snap chat
stories eine weitere funktion der app
dazu werden einzelne bilder und videos
in einem clip zusammengefasst die
follower können diesen einen tag lang
abrufen
ich mag an snap chat die direktheit
man zeigt sich dort und kann seine
geschichten teilen
die inhalte sind entweder 10 sekunden
oder 24 stunden lang verfügbar
das ist das schöne daran man teilt
einfach bestimmte momente vor zwei
jahren testete er oft pedersen snapshot
erstmals für sein kunstprojekt random
people
der 34 jährige fotografiert dafür
heimlich menschen im norwegischen
kristiansand er anonymisiert sie uns
setzt sie in einen neuen kontext
das gefällt nicht nur seinen verloren
auch internationale unternehmen wurden
auf dem grafikdesigner aufmerksam
er produzierte beispielsweise snaps für
die us-amerikanische kaffeekette
starbucks oder auch für den freizeitpark
walt disney world eine neue art des
marketings die menschen die einem folgen
schöpfen vertrauen
sie wollen sehen zu was man fähig ist
und ich glaube das ist es was
unternehmen nun realisieren
es ist ein besserer weg um ein publikum
zu erreichen deshalb interessiert sich
auch die wirtschaft für die app als
eines der wenigen deutschen unternehmen
setzt der autoverleiher sixt aufs netz
potenzielle kunden können beispielsweise
an einer testfahrt 19 mietwagens
virtuell teilnehmen
der social media leiter matthias top
seed ins netz große chancen
es gibt keine ablenkung wie beim
facebook newsfeed diverse andere inhalte
noch um einen rum publiziert werden oder
tv menschenwerk selber box woanders hin
schauen auf snapped wird die
aufmerksamkeit zu 100 prozent den inhalt
gewidmet als werbetreibender das extrem
interessant es gibt so sonst nirgends
das potenzial hat auch facebook erkannt
2013 wollte das soziale netzwerk snap
chat für umgerechnet 2,7 milliarden euro
übernehmen
doch das unternehmen aus los angeles
lehnte ab mittlerweile soll es rund fünf
mal so viel wert sein
sehr oft pedersen kann mittlerweile von
seinen aufträgen als nett influenza
leben seine follower sind zu seinen
freunden geworden
das macht so viel spaß sich mit den fans
auszutauschen und inhalte und
geschichten zu kreieren
es ist wahrscheinlich eine der besten
jobs die ich jemals hatte deswegen
können die follower von georg peters und
sicher sein
die nächsten snaps aus kristiansand
kommen bestimmt